I think we have this sense that we have
to have the roadmap all figured out
before we take that first step and we
need to know what it looks like and we
need to have that vision board and here
are the steps along the way towards
achieving my goal my goal was only to be
more authentic to who I was and trying
to more deeply discover and embrace
whatever that might be but what that
might look like I had to remain detached
from like I don't like oh I'm gonna
become a podcaster and a buddy it's like
what no like I don't even know what that
is like that didn't even exist when I
began this process so letting go of
expectations and attachment to results
remaining open and and having the
fortitude to like let go of whatever
story it is you tell yourself about who
you are and what that needs to look like
have been probably the most powerful
teachers for me
[Music]
hello and welcome to a brand new episode
of the billion podcast thank you for
joining me wherever you guys download
your podcast and listen and to those of
you who are watching this for the very
first time we are gonna try something a
little bit different here although I
can't guarantee this will be the format
moving forward is just something I'm
playing with because I do video so it
only makes sense for the two to converge
and I wanted to bring you guys a little
added value for today's guests because I
think he is that special but from a
sustainability standpoint there's nobody
behind these cameras there's nobody
monitoring the audio it is just me from
the lighting from the camera to the
audio this whole thing takes a while to
set up and it was also the case when I
visited today's guests one mr. rich roll
now to those of you who are not familiar
with rich roll and the rich roll podcast
it is one of the most popular podcasts
out there not even in the wellness space
I mean just across the board he's
brought on conversations with
celebrities with athletes wellness guru
spiritual leaders you name it he's run
the gamut and today we unpack some of
that story who he's been influenced by
when this journey started how it started
and of course the famous story of him
overcoming alcohol addiction and going
through the financial difficulty that he
did when he was trying to find as I like
to say as the overarching theme of
today's show is finding your song and
for rich it took him
it took him a good while me entering
through a career as an athlete turned
lawyer turned alcoholic and then finding
sobriety still being a little bit lost
in where his place in the world is
something I can relate to greatly and
then ultimately starting the rich roll
podcast in 2012 is approximately when it
started
it felt a little surreal I'm not gonna
lie it almost felt like I was walking
into a the set of friends or something
or the set of Seinfeld
and to be able to sit down there record
a podcast record video and sit across
from the man himself was was a little
surreal but it was pleasantly surreal
it's almost like you were pulled from
the audience and you got to engage in
act alongside Jerry Seinfeld and the
aforementioned friends cast so that part
was really cool but once I got over that
and there was the whole video set up
there too so it was a little it was a
little uncomfortable and took some
getting used to
a lot of bright lights and cameras
pointing at you and again nobody else
was behind the scenes with me monitoring
everything so a part of me was a little
bit distracted but for the most part I
think you'll enjoy today's episode we
went really long we went over just right
around 2 hours so there's a but there
was a lot to talk about again a lot to
unpack so I wanted to be sure that I had
very adequate enough time with the man
himself we talked all about his journey
as the primary focus but we also found
in to some of the burning questions I
had everything is trivial to what he
listens to both on a podcast and the
music front to some of the bigger life
themes that we cover in depth and how he
got to where he got to we also I also
want to give a plug early plug to his
live event coming up something we talked
about towards the tail end of the
episode and then please stick around at
the end of the episode when we talk
about the live event we make some
announcements or I make some
announcements and it is something that
if you can make it I would love to for
you to be a part of the event like I
said it's a two-hour episode so we're
gonna jump right into it here's my
conversation with the one and the only
[Music]
[Applause]
well rich we go from not seeing a whole
lot of each other to getting an assload
of each other in the next few weeks it's
awesome man this is long overdue by the
way yeah thank you for doing this to be
here
we were just in Montana last week mm-hmm
and today we're doing the podcast and
hopefully in the next couple weeks
you'll be there at 29 o 29 with me
suffering up and that is a plan how
swiftly I'm gonna make it up and down
that mountain dude it's not about being
Swift it's just about the whole
experience and having I'm looking
forward to it are you yeah yeah it looks
cool it looks really cool that the whole
thing is like you know just I think for
you and I maybe it's more or less like
familiar but I think for a lot of these
people this will be their first like
endurance event this type so I think
it'll be cool for that thank you for
walking me into the ritual compound yeah
I'm always welcome here the last time I
was here do you remember the last time I
was here it was for the Kilian Jornet
yeah review I think right right
but what was the other thing that
happened what's the other thing that
happened we went to lunch afterwards
right and as I was driving back I see
this big plume of smoke rising not too
far off in the distance it was day
number one of the woolsley fire yeah
that's right I totally forgot that those
two things coincided yeah this is a
bizarre set of circumstances and
honestly as I was driving away I didn't
think that much of it mm-hmm and then of
course s word spread and as a fire
spread it became this catastrophic thing
where I think at one point the compound
where your home was very much in danger
yeah it was it was pretty dicey
basically I think the fire that you saw
departing that night was the fire that
that began in Thousand Oaks yeah which
is you know like 20-some odd miles sort
of northwest or where we are
then what often gets overshadowed is the
mass shooting that took place in the
night club yeah she's also in Thousand
Oaks which is you know not that far from
our house
and I remember going to sleep that night
aware that there was a fire some
distance away and kind of grieving that
that
mass shooting but not really thinking
that we were in any kind of imminent
danger and I woke up around 6:00 the
next morning went into my container was
doing a little bit of work and then the
power went off so I was like all right
well that's interesting but not
completely unusual then some moments
later the cell service went dead and
that's never happened that's crazy so I
was like wow okay something's up I got
in my car and I drove down the street
like two miles to the corner three miles
and there on the on the on the on the
ridge line you could see the fires
everywhere pretty close to here I came
back and I was like all right we got to
get out of here
sure enough we were evacuated prior to
that though I drove down the street
there's a little neighborhood firehouse
down here just to get some intel on what
they knew and to let them know like hey
just a reminder like they know our house
and like we have a pool like you can
access it if you need it we'll leave the
gate open but we're evacuating and by
the way like what's the prognosis and
the guy said this is it like 6:30 in the
morning he's like fires gonna go all the
way to down to Malibu it's probably
gonna jump PCH like that's the danger
zone like Kanan is it's already a
foregone conclusion like yeah that's
gonna get toasted but you're probably
gonna be okay because it's just blowing
towards the beach not towards you and
sure enough that that that predict that
that prediction was totally true within
like two hours it made it all the way
down to the beach but the firefighters
did a really good job of keeping it on
the other side of Las Virgenes
which is was kind of like the
demarcation line so we were never in
huge jeopardy but it was super close and
you know we certainly have friends that
lost their homes and you probably know
some people as well that did yeah I
remember it was I forget what day that
was specifically but that Friday of that
week he might have been Thursday maybe
or may have been hear that for every day
but Friday yeah we had a film event with
Sondre we came into town with 3100 where
you were supposed to be the moderator
and the emcee right that's right and I
couldn't make it yeah and I remember
thinking to myself I kept refreshing the
fire the map as best as they can
guesstimate of where it's being affected
and because I was at your house I was
like you have rich lives right around
here and the fire was like pretty damn
close it was close
and what was wild was trying to get
accurate up-to-date information about
the fire like we'd relocated to downtown
and you really couldn't get a sense of
where it was and where it was going like
it was confusing even on Twitter I would
like key word it like with my
neighborhood and try to figure out
exactly what was happening from people
that had boots on the ground and you
just there was a lot of misinformation
and disinformation I mean I remember
hearing Malibu high school burned to the
ground
Pepperdine is gone like I was like wow
and the mall up it at Point Dume the
fire had never jumped PCH at Point Dam
Point Dume is a neighborhood that is on
this peninsula in Malibu and it's it's
generally covered in in in marine layer
like it's relatively damp and it just
never was like a target for fire but in
this case it did jump the PCH there and
there's a little shopping center there
and I heard so many reports that that
whole shopping center in the grocery
store and everything had burned to the
ground like didn't turn out to be the
truth a lot of homes were lost in Point
Dume but it was very disconcerting to
kind of not know how to separate truth
from fiction at during that period time
well never mind your home yeah our home
he spent many years countless years
building and curating and you know the
countless memories involved here was
very much at risk yeah and I I think our
relationship to this house to our home
is a little bit different than most
people
it really is you you just mentioned it a
couple minutes ago like wow this is like
a working studio and it really is like
everything that my wife and I and my
kids we've created have it's all
emanated out of this place yeah and it
does function as much as a home as it is
a workplace like you my daughter my 15
year old daughter who's an art school is
producing this huge art show for all of
her artist friends she's got six
coming she's covered the entire house
with artwork like it is a functional
studio and here we are and what used to
be a yoga room and then a bedroom that's
now the podcast studio so there's a very
you know thin demarcation line between
life and work at this place and it just
I feel like there's something special
about the energy here that has
contributed to the creations that my
wife and I have birthed into the world
and I think there's something about
having all these amazing interesting
people come to our house to do the
podcast that I feel like or I choose to
believe kind of emboldened this place
with like good inspirational energy yeah
I feel that energy for sure yeah and we
can go on the whole Jagga but look you
can't you can't replace human beings and
family members and loved ones and these
are just things but you know they're and
talk about mindfulness but you are who
you are a human being after all 9 I know
I was following your journey as this was
happening in real time and you were
trying to ride that that balance of
putting things into perspective there
are people that you know for sure who
lost our homes well yours are still in
peril but at the same time I mean come
on this is like I don't know how you
slept a wink as this was happening well
you have to you have to surrender to
what is I mean truly you are powerless
over these things and that's a lesson
that I've you know had to learn and
relearn time and time again over the
course of my journey my utter
powerlessness not only over drugs and
alcohol but essentially over everything
people yes situations all that you can
control is your response to what is and
when you're faced with something like
your house burning down you're compelled
to confront that in a very fundamental
way and of course who wants that you
know we built this home it's a beautiful
home I'm so lucky and fortunate to be
able to live here and the prospect that
it would get taken away from me
certainly that's gonna you know provoke
all of your you know all the gamut of
human emotions but at some point you
have to kind of like step into what it
would feel like to be in that reality
and being
in acceptance I've got a friend Darren
Oh lien podcasts about on the podcast a
couple times purchased this amazing
property right off cane and this little
hunting lodge that was built like in the
early 1900s just a tiny little house but
on this you know incredible parcel of
land and this was gonna be like this is
you know his new like it's just it was
an incredible home property etc he was
out of the country completely burned to
the ground everything like his his truck
just disappeared like everything was
gone there was no opportunity no like
salad anything he wasn't there to get
anything out of it like everything that
he owned was gone and yeah he had a
moment of like oh my lord but then very
quickly recalibrated to this is amazing
like I have this opportunity now to
rebuild this in a way that really suits
me and I think that example that he set
was a model for like how I would like to
navigate something yeah I'm not sure
that I could but but it's pretty cool to
see somebody who really Crocs like stuff
is stuff right on a very very very very
micro level I'm somebody who obsessively
keeps tabs open on their browsers uh-huh
and every now and again every once in a
blue moon the computer will reboot or
will restart or the browser will close
erasing everything that I had earmarked
that I'm gonna go back to my better yeah
but then I think about it I was like
well I can't recall 80% of the taps I
had open and this is kind of nice
actually
yeah like starting from scratch it's
kind of like select all delete in your
inbox yeah well I've never done that
that's great have you know I know sure
how you thought I've had to make peace
with just thousands of emails being
unread yeah
pensee automated respond right what you
don't know how effective that is but
anyway well you mentioned your journey
Richard role we should probably talk
about that and I don't want to maybe
overlap too much you've told your story
several times your story about finding
endurance you know in turn sports
through
the entire arc of your journey which is
fascinating I don't mean to diminish it
by fast-tracking through it but maybe we
should set it up for people who aren't
familiar with your entire story or who
haven't read the book which I would
highly recommend so all right so how far
back you want to go
I mean how I can I can rifle through
this pretty quickly I mean I grew up
Washington DC two loving parents
middle-class until I was high school and
my dad became a partner in his law firm
and then we had you know all the
resources that a family of four would
require all my needs were met but I was
a kid who was always kind of lonely kind
of awkward insecure had difficulty
making friends just generally you know
that kid in the corner right who was
picked last for kickball and all that
stuff
bullied when I was younger until I
discovered swimming which was something
that I showed some level of natural
acumen for and when you're a kid and you
you show some promise in something
that's what you're going to gravitate
towards I certainly did and and swimming
initially kind of really saved me and by
the time I was a senior in high school I
was one of the more prominent swimmers
in my area I got recruited at colleges
Swimming helped helped me become a
better student I had always struggled in
school but was able to kind of crack
that code and graduate near the top of
my class and got into all the great
colleges and was faced with the decision
of whether to go to an Ivy League and be
a big fish in a small pond in the
Swimming World or go to Stanford and be
a very small fish in a very in the
largest pond available to me and that's
what I opted for because I felt like I
couldn't I couldn't say to myself that I
had really explored every option to you
know tap into my ultimate potential if I
if I declined an opportunity to share a
lane with a guy who has the world record
in my event so I did that ultimately I
don't know that it was the best the best
program for me
because it was so focused on world
champions and Olympic gold medal or was
Harvard in terms of like I mean heard a
really good program they had some really
great swimmers including a guy Dave
Birkhoff who who went to the Olympics
and had American record could be more or
less verbally committed yeah i did i
i've verbally committed to harvard
because who says no to harvard who am i
to do that like oh my lord you know i
got into Harvard are you kidding me
visited Stanford as an afterthought at
the last minute thinking well I just
need to see this place before I you know
fully check it off the list and went for
a recruiting trip there and just I just
fell in love with hell to me I was just
incredible I've never really been to
California before and I just thought oh
my god this place is like it's like no
college campus I've ever seen everybody
seemed really happy and engaged and they
seemed to enjoy life while also you know
being dedicated to academic excellence
and also excellence in other areas of
the life in their lives in a way that
was celebrated by the community and I
felt like there was something antiquated
or old-school about these Ivy League
institutions where it was just like you
pick athlete athletics or academics and
you can't do both and you know I don't
know there was an open mindedness that's
it was very California about Stanford
that really appealed to me and was so
different from the way that I was
brought up and I just thought I have to
go to school here so I did and I loved
it I'm not sure it was the best thing
for my swimming career but that
experience was incredible but it
coincided with me really experimenting
with alcohol for the first time I mean I
got drunk a couple times prior to that
but when I got to college and I was
3,000 miles away from my home I felt
like I had this opportunity to reinvent
myself and I just you know tapped into
the social scene and the partying scene
there and and it really helped me come
out of my skin
it helped it teach me how to be a social
animal and there were a lot of good
things that came out of that and I had
an amazing time but I knew early on that
I had
an unhealthy relationship with alcohol
but I just continued to you know kind of
go down that path for a very long time
and it was a slow process of my
aspirations being eroded and my life if
there was one environment where
something like that feels quote-unquote
normal it is this College yes so it's
easy to go like well I'm in college you
know who cares if I but if I'm the last
guy to leave the party or I passed out
in the corner terrible hair of the dog
at 9:00 a.m. so it's alright a lot of
people were doing that and then what
happens over time though is you keep
doing that and everyone else kind of
slowly stops doing and you have fewer
and fewer friends to call up to join you
in those kinds of activities because
they start to like you know become
responsible members of society whereas
like I'm like come on let's keep doing
this right so so my alcoholism
you know manifested slowly over an
extended period of time I mean after
college I went to New York City and
that's where it really kind of began to
explode as I say in the book it's like
Disneyland for alcoholics you can walk
around with open container and take cabs
and you have to worry about driving and
you can stay out till 3:00 in the
morning and that's socially acceptable
being in New York is yeah
and it's fun right I had an amazing time
went to law school and that's where it
started to kind of get dark because I
realized I couldn't put it down and you
know just continued to progress like I
look back on my law school experience
and I wonder like how I made it through
that and then went to San Francisco was
a young associate and a law firm there
and it just wasn't the career for me it
was one of those things where I felt
like I became a lawyer just because I
felt like the right thing to do not
because I had any passion for it and and
because I didn't have any passion for it
it was very difficult for me to apply
myself in that environment and that
meant that when I had free time like at
night I would just go out like super
late and show up hungover and you know
it just got darker and lonelier there's
nothing there's nothing really super
sexy or romantic or rock-and-roll about
my drinking career it just was a slow
progression to a sad and lonely pathetic
life that ultimately at the end
I moved you know it ended up in a
marriage that ended on the honeymoon and
I'm in Los Angeles sleeping out a
mattress you know on the floor of a
otherwise essentially unfurnished
apartment trying to hold it together at
a law firm there but the cracks you know
we're starting to show and I got two
duis in rapid succession my boss knew
what was going on I was facing jail time
I got my license suspended I injured an
elderly woman and in a car accident like
[ __ ] was going sideways quickly and
ultimately you know I ended up in I
ended up in rehab in 1998 when I was 31
years old and and I spent a hundred days
yeah rehab and as somebody who likes to
think of himself as a relatively
intelligent person manoah's not lost on
me that my best thinking had delivered
me to what is essentially a mental
institution yeah I mean it's it's always
interesting because the context is
important obviously and your journey is
so so interesting to me personally
because I can relate to it there was a
there's always a point of despair or a
long period of despair and you feel like
you haven't quite as you put it so
delicately in the book found your song
found that found that thing to point
your compass towards and so your overall
story has been covered on several
podcasts what really interests me though
about your story is the period from
after the book ends to where we are
right now you broke this incredible
podcast Empire I know I jokingly called
you the pot father but I mean you are
you've created this amazing thing that
people may discount quickly as something
that well right time you know right
moment kind of thing but you know things
when the book ends it doesn't it's not
this Hollywood ending that everything
becomes okay because you found endurance
sports and because you found a career
career you were at a point after the
book were things were in pretty dire
financial straits yeah you had a family
to support several more mouths to feed
after you met Julie like talk about that
time and when things really got
from that point like how how did you
find your way out of it and discover
podcasting so the book comes out
initially in 2012 and I realized that
the publication of this book presented
an opportunity for me to fundamentally
change my career path because at that
time still I was practicing law not do I
wasn't doing it super successfully and
it was kind of part-time but officially
I was still a lawyer and I thought I
have this book coming out I have this
opportunity like I need to really invest
all of myself into getting this out
there because that could create
opportunities for me to change what I do
for a living because I was so unhappy
being a lawyer and I guess I thought
like I knew look thousands and thousands
of books come out every year most of
them come and go so I'm really gonna
have to give my all to this if I wanted
to turn into something sustainable that
can ultimately at some point support my
family in ways that I I don't even know
what that would look like right now so I
did do that and I thought if I did that
that somehow some doors would open that
would lead me in some sort of direction
and what I quickly found out was that I
mean first of all you know I wasn't
really outside of you know the small the
small subculture of endurance and ultra
endurance like nobody knew who I was
really so I had to try to get my name
out there more broadly so it wasn't like
it was some big New York Times
bestseller at the time and I did what I
could do and that cycle kind of ran its
course and was over and there I was like
at home going alright what's next and
the phone wasn't really ringing and
those opportunities that I trusted would
come weren't really coming and how tough
was that by was really hard so much into
spilling your guts and telling the
underbelly well I didn't have it wasn't
a sense of being wronged or anything
like that like I didn't feel like I
there was an expectation or that I
deserved anything more or that I or that
you know but you Harbor some dreams
right yeah that works it be and I was
like alright well this isn't happening
like what are we gonna do now like we
don't really have money coming
and you know I have four kids and we
have a mortgage and all these sort of
real-life pressures were happening and
it was very very challenging and Julie
has all my life has always been somebody
who kind of you know as this lighthouse
like holds this center of gravity where
she's like we have to just keep moving
forward you know and I and I really
credit her for having strength when I
didn't because there were plenty of
times where I was like I got a you know
just get go find some law firm job you
know so I can make the income to support
this family she's like you cannot do
that we have come too far we have to see
this through whatever that looks like
and the analogy that I always use I mean
you're much younger than me but they're
I don't know if you've ever watched the
old Popeye cartoons yeah
so there's one cartoon where sweet pea
the little baby gets lost like she
crawls off and finds herself on a
construction site and she crawls up into
an i-beam and the i-beam gets raised by
a crane and it's like hundreds of feet
above the ground one of the things for
Sweet Pea keeps going keeps going in
somehow right she's crawling and then
right when she's about to crawl off the
end of this i-beam that's hanging you
know hundreds of feet above the ground
and other eye beings swings right to it
and she crawls right onto that like and
I feel like that's how our life went
like right when it was like oh this is
over at the Mary at the very last minute
something would come that would allow us
to you know keep going and look there's
a lot of embarrassing emasculating
you know incidents along the way like we
had cars repossessed like we couldn't
even pay for our garbage bins and they
got the city came and took them away so
we had to put GART that got our garbage
in the back of our one crappy minivan
that we still had and like drive it to
some dumpster that we could find like it
was a it was a lot of like really you
know just like I can't believe this is
what our life is that moment about
you're handing over a card and you're
not quite sure if it's going to go
though it wasn't going through you know
you know down to just having like okay
what do you have in your wallet like
what alive and what can we do with this
and and trying to detach
are are like judgment from those
situations and turn it into like a game
like okay here's what we're doing like
we're playing the game of life this is
what we got like roll the dice was
helpful and and constantly trusting that
you know a were being tested for a
reason like believing in that having
faith that's something greater you know
was waiting for us and continuing to do
the work and what happened is that you
know just like sweet pea certain things
which show up you know right when you
were at that moment of losing faith
completely and one of those things was
that a friend who had read well somebody
who had become a friend I didn't know
him that well at the time had read
finding altro I was inspired by it he
reached out to me his name was Chris jab
and he was a guy who who had been a
successful entrepreneur he was Mark
Cuban's partner in broadcast comm and
that was when that IPO happened it was
like the most successful IPO of all we
bought the Mavericks and he exactly and
so whereas mark went on to continue to
be an entrepreneur and build his empire
Chris was like I'm good I don't you know
I got plenty you know I don't need
anymore
and ended up moving his family to the
North Shore of Kauai and by buying this
old mango farm and turning it into this
property called common ground where he
had a restaurant and he had these
beautiful grounds and he reached out to
me and he said look I have this thing
and I'm not really sure what to do with
it it has so much potential I want to
figure out a way to leverage it to give
back or to create a community space and
I just need help you know I da ting
around what this could be like would you
be interested in helping me which was a
very strange like it's not like I'm an
expert in property development or
anything like that he just connected
with me in some way as a result of the
book and we had nothing else going on
and he was you know willing to pay for
us to do this so our whole family
relocated common ground on the North
Shore of Hawaii we lived in a village of
yurts that he had on this organic farm
and we spent a couple months where I was
collaborating with him over these ideas
and ultimately
that didn't really amount to anything he
just you know he couldn't wrap his head
around what he wanted to do or whatever
flips a little that's right and
simultaneously I started to develop like
some Island fever because I'd worked so
hard to like create something and I
really wanted to connect with people and
I felt I'm on this island like so far
away from the mainland I was feeling
very isolated and also thinking about
what the next creative expression could
be because the book had kind of come and
you know had done its thing and I'd
always been a fan of podcasts I'd listen
to podcast when I was training for these
races I was very much an early adopter
when it was you know wonky if you wanted
to listen to a podcast you had to
download it on your desktop or your
laptop and then you had to balance that
mp3 file to your iPod like it was a
thing like you had to be very
intentional about your your playlist if
you were if it was the podcast this is
arm walking six miles to school right
yeah this is our veer wasn't a when you
understand that technology wasn't quite
there and the podcast space was very
much a hobbyist space yeah but there
were some big creators I mean Adam
Carolla was doing his thing and I
started listening to him from day one
and and and like kind of was there for
the evolution of him trying to figure
out how to turn you know this into
something that was financially viable
and kind of shared about that along the
way I mean Rogen's started pretty early
so the comedians were the first ones in
that that was the mo most robust you
know developed space in the in the
podcast world but for the things that I
was interested in like Fitness of
training and endurance sports and there
was only a smattering of a few things
out there and and I saw like an
opportunity I was like I know some cool
people like I had listened to thousands
of hours of podcast and it always like
confused me because I felt like I was
the only one like there I know you
because we had crossed paths early on
and I knew you were listening to some of
the stuff that I was like oh yeah I was
Adam Carolla's right we talked about
you know all of that but I was always
like I never listen to radio again after
that and I couldn't understand why
everyone else wasn't on board right and
you know like yeah
why are you passively listening to
somebody else's decision about what you
should be listening to instead of like
intentionally curating your experience
this is available or if there's
something that you're really engaged in
you can stop and start it and break it
up exactly where you left off exactly
stead of sitting in your car you know
listening to the radio before you wanted
to work and you didn't have to be a
computer programmer to figure it out I
mean wasn't that hard so anyway I just
felt like maybe there's something I can
do in this space and wizards sorry to
interject but was there somebody at this
time we're talking about like 2012 at
this 2011 s 11 late 2011 okay who was
currently in that space where you're
like okay I see what they're doing and I
know rogue in somebody like Rogan was
instrumental in your in your start but
was in the Wellness space where the
endurance space that that you saw what
they were doing but you thought you
could do something well I think for it
it wasn't ever that I thought I could do
anything better I think there were I
think endurance planet existed then
Gordo Gordo Byrne who had won Ultraman
and was a coach in Boulder at the time
would occasionally throw a podcast where
he would talk about events or he would
interview athletes and he ended up just
doing it sporadically once in a while
but I was like this is so valuable to me
like just to hear somebody who's better
at this who has more experience in this
world than I do to share their
experience like that was incredible
who else there was a there was a couple
triathlon podcasts there was Zen in the
art of triathlon Brett plank Turner who
became a friend but all of these were
very much hobbyists right and and you
know I think Rogan you know he'd been
going for a while at this point and I'd
been it early guy I was like episode 200
something on his show so I had been when
my book came out I had the opportunity
to be a guest on certain shows and so I
got a glimpse of like how certain yeah
you made on Corolla
I did Corolla and he was the first
person to really take it and
and do it in a very professional way
yeah built this incredible studio and he
was like I'm running this like a
business I'm not a hobbyist yeah it was
basically bringing the radio show
exactly podcast yeah so so I thought
well let me give this a whirl my sons
who were musicians had equipment they
had you know mics and stuff like that
and I went online and spent a day I mean
I've been thinking about this for a
while I just hadn't done anything about
it and I was just like you know I was in
the it was it was a timing thing because
I was in Hawaii and I was like I need to
do something creative and I went on Pat
Flynn from smart passive income had
created a series of YouTube videos
entitled how to start a podcast and he
literally walked through every single
thing that you needed to do from every
piece of equipment to how you get you
know hosting and how you get the feed
that goes on at you know onto iTunes and
you know it seems like it should be
easier like there's a lot of weird like
steps that are janky still about stars
oh yeah that's like you and it took me
like a day of like taking notes and I
just did everything that he said like
and to get it all like set up and then
my wife and I sat in a warehouse on this
property common ground it turned a mic
on and we just had a conversation and I
didn't know whether I would ever have a
second one I didn't know whether I would
like share this at all it wasn't like oh
I'm doing a podcast and here's what's
gonna look like and here's the vision it
was like that was fun like let's do it
tomorrow you know like and that was it
really
but if you go back and listen to episode
1 which I have yeah oh have you liked it
when I was starting my own podcasting
journey and I had this same level of
intimidation not only when it comes to
gear and like what do i what kind of
mike swagger what kind of recorder do i
get but it was really about a holy [ __ ]
like there's all these steps and I mean
let alone just being competent at write
so I figured one thing I would do was
like okay you know what I'll do I'll go
back and listen to the first few
episodes of the podcast site currently
listen to that's super polished super
great your podcast Rogen's podcasts
Corollas podcast and I went back and
that gave me the confidence
this is really know what the actual
content of what you guys were doing was
super good I think you're a natural in
this medium and I think you finally you
were this fish-out-of-water that finally
found your stream - or your lake or your
river whatever body of water you want to
use as an analogy but that part that
part was still like oh [ __ ] like this
guy is really confident at this he seems
to be a natural at this
I'm not but it was more or less like the
technical aspects of it like the reverb
in the bounce I mean we had you know
mics that are meant for musicians and
and I made the genius decision of like
doing it in a warehouse that had
probably the worst acoustics of all time
like this cavernous space with all this
echo I mean it was bad but if you go
back and listen to that I do say
something along the lines of like look I
don't know what this is gonna be or if
it will even be but I can tell you one
thing and that is that this is not going
to be a podcast about training for
triathlons or like really super focused
on the granular aspects of being an
athlete like I want to I want to expand
my horizons because I have a lot of more
I have a lot more growth to do and I did
want to convene with interesting people
across the board in various areas and I
feel like I've held true to that and and
I think the lesson in all of this is not
being afraid to just begin and allowing
yourself to be imperfect and and being
okay with that like okay I'll figure
this out over time like I'm putting this
out you know
and it's not great but like that's the
only way that you can be a creator is to
you know be in the process of sharing
that evolution you know in real time
yeah and you took it somewhat vaguely or
generally about higher power having
faith in something beyond yourself and
beyond this world and for both what you
and I do I think there's also a timing
aspect of it that was crucial yeah
because clearly you couldn't do this if
the technology didn't exist or it wasn't
starting to take shape and I couldn't do
what I do video content podcasting if we
weren't of a certain time like it's
really interesting if we look back even
in the last
five years right of how technology has
evolved and how readily accessible even
something like podcast is with anchor
and you know some some of these other
businesses that have like really
streamlined the process a lot more but
back to n man it was like like you said
they were where you couldn't pull up
thousands of videos on how to start a
podcast now mm-hmm
it was you really had to search for it
and find it yes oh I I think two things
I mean first of all you could say like I
was a little bit ahead of the curve
because podcasting had not been sort of
widely or broadly embraced at that time
but I very much benefited from being an
early adopter it's like the one thing
that I wear that I've done where I was
like in the right place at the right
time because it wasn't a crowded
marketplace now there's like 750,000
podcasters doing like that but at this
time people it was not cool to have a
podcast people weren't scrambling to
start podcasts at the time so and there
weren't there wasn't that much going on
in the health space for sure so when I
launched the podcast it immediately was
in like the top you know 50 podcasts on
iTunes and it was in you know
consistently in the top three in the
health sector and I was getting I mean I
think the first episode got maybe two
thousand downloads or something like
that like it didn't take much because
there was nothing going on at the time
but that gave me the encouragement and
the feet I was like wow like this went
right to this thing like this is
connecting in a way that that you know
seems pretty immediate and I think that
encouraged me and and gave me the energy
to like keep going and building upon it
and did you have a decent social media
following at the time and said how you
got the word out I mean yes and no I
mean I have a huge it wasn't super huge
or anything like that I mean this was I
mean did Instagram even exist yeah it
did exist but it was still Instagram was
still small at that time use letter I
had a couple hundred no I never did
email until I'm still not great at that
that you know I don't have like some big
email
I mean it was really I think Twitter was
probably the main thing at the time but
maybe I had I don't know 15,000
followers or something like that I
didn't have some massive I had a little
bit of notoriety because of the book
right but it was still very much in that
endurance space so it's just I've never
had like some viral moments I mean
everything that I've done is just been
slow progressive organic growth over
time and I did the podcast for over two
years before there was any kind of
monetization of it so it wasn't like oh
this is a cash grab like you know it
took a long time to grow the audience to
a scale in which trying to convert it
for some kind of commercial enterprise
even made sense when was your first
holy-shit moment like I can't believe
who I'm sitting across and I'm trying to
keep my cool but this person that I've
long admired is sitting across from me
uh I think I that's a great question I
mean there's been plenty of those
I mean episode two was was Gabby Reece
because she was like the one person on
Kauai yeah why she was living there and
not only were Laird and Gabby living on
Kauai they would come to common ground
every day to eat so they were around you
know and they were accessible and Gabby
was teaching an exercise class in that
same warehouse where we were recording
the podcast so you know episode two I'm
already sitting across from you know
this amazing human being so it was
almost like immediately like oh this is
a great way to like sit down with
amazing interesting people I think look
there's been many there's been numerous
incidents where I've had that oh my god
I can't believe I'm meeting this person
you know you've all know a Harare that
was incredible
but that wasn't that long ago as a
couple years ago you know Tony Hawk like
name all these people like it's just
it's been absolutely bananas but I think
for me the greater satisfaction is
always when I find somebody who I think
is amazing who I feel like more people
should know about but they don't and I
get to introduce that person and their
incredible story to the audience and
then watch like observe from a
distance how that story and that
individual connects that's really
gratifying like that happened with Josh
Lujan II who was just a you know an
average dude living in southern
Louisiana who was like enormous ly
overweight and changed his life and in a
way that in any so charismatic and such
a beautiful guy but like he was just an
anonymous human being and that was
really cool or John McAvoy who was this
career criminal in the UK who you know
went to prison for a very long time and
supervisors like yeah like people in the
UK kind of are familiar with his story
but in America people didn't know who
that was
and to be able to be like hey I found
this guy like check this out and half
people go just have him blow their minds
like that's really cool well the first
name that came to mind when he told me
that was your interview January 2nd I
think it was 2017 with David Coggins
right David Collins look for the people
out there they may be thinking well
David Collins has been part of my life
that's an entire time where it feels
that way he's making the rounds he's
he's a household name people are sharing
videos and you know clips and he's blown
up right but as because I follow date
with David Collins early on back in
2006-2007 I think it was a runner's
world article or something where holy
[ __ ] this guy is this guy is a different
animal right this guy is somebody who's
inspiring the [ __ ] out of me and even
when there weren't like a whole lot of
YouTube videos at the time I remember
those as video of his journey at like
McNaughton which is this 130 mile race
and out in Chicago and and this is
badass who's doing this race and he's
doing at the end of it he he does a
bunch of jumping jacks it'd be like why
what's up you know I'm so I'm so doing
this and I'm still kicking ass and that
interview which was long overdue to
really introduce Goggins to the
mainstream hasn't been properly done and
it wasn't until you sat down with them
where I discovered even more details
about how his upbringing how he came to
be David
[ __ ] Loggins yeah and it blew my mind
yeah it's quite an arc
that guy has been on I mean now he's got
millions of people you know following
him on Instagram every time puts up one
of those little inspirational clips of
him you know delivering his cussing at
the cameras always running gets you know
I like I'll look at it be like wow half
a million people have watched us in the
last four hours like it's it's amazing
and well-deserved because you know he he
is incredibly inspirational and it's
incredible that he's now essentially a
household name a guy who self-published
a book that basically outsold every book
on Amazon except for Michelle Obama's
you know biography it's it's really
quite something but if you're somebody
who has been in the endurance world for
a number of years and certainly the
ultra endurance world
you know David Goggins like this guy has
been around for a very long time and in
fact when I was getting interested in
this world and hadn't yet done anything
it was an article about Ultraman that
featured David Goggins that originally
inspired me even tackle this event
because he had just done bad water and
then he did ultraman he got second and
he had to like tape his running shoe to
a pedal of his bike as a crazy story
right I thought this guy he's not really
even a triathlete he doesn't like to
swim at all he's not very good swimmer
like right exactly and and so he had
inspired me from afar and I kind of
followed him over the years and then he
kind of disappeared from the the
endurance world he had some health
problems and the like and I had reached
out to him in the early days of the
podcast to try to share his story and it
kind of fell on deaf ears or he wasn't
ready or whatever and that yeah in like
late 2016 his fiancee then-girlfriend
reached out to me and was like Dave's
ready to talk if you're still interested
in doing the podcast like let's do it
and he hadn't done any podcast you don't
hadn't done any media no one had really
heard from him in any material way in a
very long time yeah you had a heart
condition yeah a heart condition all
these sorts of things and so I was like
absolutely and I went and did it and it
was everything that I hoped it would be
and it didn't surprise me because I
already you know I knew his story and
all that kind of stuff I didn't realize
how much that would connect with
ball like that just that was probably
the you know that was a defining moment
in the history of my podcast because yes
he you know he was a very distinct voice
that people hadn't heard of or weren't
familiar with and I feel a lot of pride
and gratitude that I was able to
introduce him to a lot of people and I
think you know look I I I have to
believe that you know he he was aware
him and his fiancee were aware of how
much that connected with people and I
think that emboldened them to you know
basically become more public and what
David was doing that in that obviously
ultimately ultimately led to him write
in this book and and now he's like on
all the podcasts and he came back and
did mine again but you know he's it's
very cool to see him go and do all these
other shows and and reach as many people
as he has but yeah I think it really did
it began you know back and that day and
and and it's also amazing to see we
talked about this the other day but it's
amazing to see his personal evolution
and all of this if you go back and I
mean he's essentially kind of a shot
he's a very shy guy fundamentally if you
go back there's a video on YouTube of an
interview with him right after he
finished his first badwater mm-hmm
and Chris Kaufman's trying to interview
him and David set aside the fact that
he's completely exhausted like that's a
given of course and that's going to
impact like how you're you're gonna be
in an interview but he was so awkward
and he really couldn't even make eye
contact with Chris or I believe it was
Chris that was interviewing him and he's
very kind of insecure and his word
choice in his language like it was
almost like he really didn't know how to
communicate with another human being
well the version of David Goggin said he
talks about in the book yeah and when
you when you when you contrast that with
how he communicates today it's
incredible he's channeling David Goggins
yes
David [ __ ] Goggins good [ __ ] GOG
it's it's like he takes on this other
persona yeah is there a degree of that
with you to where you feel at times like
that that shy awkward cross-eyed kid you
know can you go back to that headspace
you know I'm still a shy awkward
insecure
very much so and I'm kind of a loner
like I can like I do public speaking now
and obviously podcast and they live but
you have to get up for it yeah but I
have to really gear up like it's not
wrong you see people who are natural
performers and they can kind of do that
and it doesn't seem to take a toll on
them for me it takes a lot of energy for
me to do that because I you know I like
to you know basically close the door in
my container and be left alone so I can
gear up for it but it's a practice like
look you know I've done 450 whatever
episodes of the podcast like a thousand
hours of talking yeah you know you're
gonna get better at it just by virtue of
the doing right and being placed in
these situations that that initially
feel awkward but that you just acclimate
to over time 52 years on this big blue
marble can you take a step back and
objectively look at where you've gone in
the trajectory of your life and and
actually take the time to feel that
level of pride and or are you constantly
this fish movie well yeah that's that's
the tension like I'm aware like I'm but
my natural disposition is like what's
next what's wrong what's not working why
is it not working and to focus on the
problems I have to really go out of my
way
to just be present with what's happening
and be grateful and acknowledge you know
the this incredible trajectory ahead
I've been blessed to be I'm like I could
have never imagined that this would be
my life you know I often reflect back on
being in a career that that I really was
ill-suited to me and made me very
unhappy and having no sense of what I
could possibly do that could provide my
life with fulfillment and yet you had
the misfortune of being good at it and
it's just kind of like it could short
force myself to be okay at it you know I
think in Miles's for me really is is is
that when you have the fortitude to
commit to personal growth
whatever that in whatever form or
process that looks like for you and you
have the faith to just move forward
blindly without knowing where it's gonna
lead you I think that's where you create
the opportunity for amazing things to
transpire I think we have this sense
that we have to have the roadmap I'll
figure it out before we take that first
step and we need to know what it looks
like and we need to have that vision
board and here are the steps along the
way towards achieving my goal my goal
was only to be more authentic to who I
was and trying to more deeply discover
and embrace whatever that might be but
what that might look like I had to
remain detached from like I like oh I'm
gonna become a podcaster and I put it
it's like what no like I don't even know
what that is like that didn't even exist
when I began this process so letting go
of expectations and attachment to
results remaining open and and having
the fortitude to like let go of whatever
story it is you tell yourself about who
you are and what that needs to look like
have been probably the most powerful
teachers for me in the realm of mindset
look you clearly have to show that's
resonating with people changing people's
lives like that is ultimately going to
be your legacy but I'm sure you're not
without some level of scrutiny
skepticism you know public just backlash
right and take something like Lance
Armstrong for example was that difficult
to you know build something that is
impacting a bunch of people's lives in a
positive way being a really bright
beacon for people and then doing
something like that and you get the
disproportionate number of people saying
like [ __ ] you why are you having Lance
on your pot guys like I mean you've
clearly tried to set it up - hey I
understand this is what he did in his
past lifetime I want to just have a
conversation with them and be unbiased
and approach this in a very objective
manner but still you're human being at
the end of the day
yeah and the for the thousands of likes
or whatever public and log
acknowledgment that you get that one
level of criticism wool well just like
yeah I mean more you know I'm not a I'm
not a stranger to the hate mail and the
hate you know all of that kind of
backlash I've received I got a like a
gnarly email yesterday that like bummed
me out you know somebody likes saying
you know I've lost my way and you know
everybody has their opinion and I think
that's okay
like if you're putting yourself out
there to the world and you're not
getting some kind of pushback then
you're probably not you know trying hard
enough I think it goes with the
territory gets you safe yeah you're
being too safe and I would say I'm I'm
probably too safe in general already you
know I I think that I would I would be
well served by having more people on my
show that I disagree with or have a
worldview that is at odds with my own
and trying to be open-minded about that
and you know that's something I spend a
lot of time thinking about I mean in the
case of Lance my approach with that was
exactly what you said like I wasn't
there to do a referendum and pass
judgment on his life I was there to try
to better understand the experience of a
human being who has gone through what
very few people on earth have
experienced which is to have these super
high highs and these super low lows and
how do you move forward through those
low lows and what is the emotional
experience of that and you know people
emotions run high with Lance everybody
enters into entered into that
conversation with a with a already
completely formed opinion and judgment
of who he is and as I said in the
introduction to that like this
conversation is not going to change that
you know if you're a big fan of Lance
you'll probably come out of this as a
big fan of Lance if you already have a
distaste for him then you know this
conversation probably going to change
that but I don't regret having it you
know I think that we have to have
conversations like that I just my most
recent episode is with Amanda Palmer the
musician and performance artist and one
of the things we talked about in that is
is radical compassion you know and she
talks about this need that we have to be
more empathetic to human beings and and
to express that empathy not when it's
convenient when that person falls in
line with our worldview but to have the
capacity to to express love and
understanding and compassion when
somebody's actions or ideology is
completely at odds with us and I think
we need more of that now because we're
in a culture that is extremely divided
in a very acrimonious way and I spent a
lot of time worrying about how we're
gonna find our way back to to unity and
our ability to simply co-exist together
in a healthy functional way and I think
you know empathy and understanding is
really the only only way to do that well
I almost feel like when it comes to
because social media is certainly
amplifies a sure that all the negativity
and the voices everyone has a platform
everyone has an opinion that they can
voice now in a public forum and I will
sing this about where I was thinking
this about Twitter like what if if you
were to engage in someone say
politically that you had to that you
couldn't write it out you had to use
video imagine if people communicated
that way in short whatever 15 30-second
clips to go back and forth and engage
that way instead of through words and
these pithy like f you write you know
like well first of all your face would
make you accountable for who you are so
you couldn't be a bot right are you
gonna be a hike hide behind some avatar
yeah and I think there's something about
reading somebody's facial expression
that creates context in nuance in a way
that just text doesn't but I think at
the same time it you still have a
situation in which people are shouting
past each other you know and if you're
gonna make a video like okay what do I
want and what exactly am I saying
there's a performative element to that
as well that I think still remains
problematic what do you think it's the
solutions fault is how do we
how do we ratchet down the hate and the
negativity that's out there especially
when it comes to the world of politics
that's so I mean I don't I don't purport
to have the magic bullet solution to
that but I do believe and feel strongly
in the power of long-form conversations
to be a healing agent because they do
allow for nuance and they do allow for
you know space and time to breathe where
you can really get a sense of where
somebody's coming from you know so it's
easy to malign a certain individual like
oh that person said this one thing
because I saw it on this clip and you
don't even really understand the context
but if you sit across from somebody for
two for two hours and ask him all these
kind of questions you'll get a better
sense of where that person is coming
from which is somebody like Rogan comes
to mind when who handles it yeah well I
think I think he's you know he's very
good at what he does and he's he's
courageous in his guest selection like
he just said Bernie Sanders on but he's
also had tulsi gabbard on and Andrew
yang he'll have Alex Jones on you know
like I don't know how it's like it's
crazy how he can get away with all you
know he can have anybody he wants on and
nothing he's like Teflon nothing ever
sticks to him and I think that's the way
it should be just because you have a
tricky guest on your show doesn't mean
that you align with that person's
pointed right but he creates that
environment for a conversation which is
what I think is missing criticism heads
yeah shouting Eddie's right right and
that's that's the path forward the
criticism that you get is that you're if
you have somebody on who has a
controversial point of view your
platforming them you're giving them a
platform but I think you have to be able
to have these kinds of conversations I
think Sam Harris does an amazing job
with this as well we have to be able to
have uncomfortable conversations if we
want to heal this gaping wound I agree
with you 100% and that's why I didn't
take any exception to having Lance
Armstrong on or you could have been she
puroland you could have Bernie Sanders
on and I would still I think it would be
an interesting listen I want to I'm
curious about ritual the public figure
because clearly
you're this cover boy for health and
wellness and and fitness I mean people
have used your likeness for Christ here
some of that how do you so I mean you're
what 52 now yeah I'm coming up on 53
pretty quick your hair's going great
that but you still have lots of it man
so thank God for that how do you deal
with that how do you deal with when
somebody sees you or maybe they're
running next to you on a trail like how
do you look do you know what I'm saying
how do you reconcile the the need to
sort of live up to a certain set of
expectations to be this person that
people may have in their minds I try not
to think about it too much
look when somebody comes up to me and
says hey I love the podcast or hey you
know you helped me with X Y or Z like
what an incredible gift that is like I I
don't I can't imagine considering that
an annoyance now if I'm with my you know
youngest daughter and somebody and I'm
in the middle of doing something with
her and somebody interrupts like it can
be tricky sometimes but I'm always super
grateful to meet anybody who because I'm
just like I'm at my house putting stuff
out into the world the fact that I like
somebody walks up to me in an airport
like it just blows my mind that that
that that is even happening at all so
I'm there's nothing more gratifying than
putting something out that has a
positive impact on somebody else and
when I can get that feedback from
somebody else that encourages me to keep
going like that's the fuel I live for
that stuff so I don't have any kind of
problem with that at all and it's at a
level now where it's very manageable
like you know it's not like you know
some movie stars who can't go outside
and have to deal with all kinds of
craziness like it's it's you know
infrequent at best and always kind of
like a pleasant you know interlude so
whatever's happening so that's all good
no problem whatsoever
you know you know if you see me out in
the world please come up to me and say
hello like I love it in terms of trying
to make sure that I live up to some
expectation of what people have of me I
mean that gets tricky like it's him if
somebody meets me they're going to be
projecting a version of me on to me
because they don't really know me right
they listen to my podcast so there's an
intimate as you know like there's an
intimacy with that like you are in a
relationship with that person on some
level but it's more imagined and than
real and so somebody will think like Oh
on this that and the other and you know
no matter what that looks like it's not
real
so I can't get caught up in what that is
but I would say I feel a responsibility
to walk the walk like I can't I can't
you know be on the microphone talking
about all these subject matters if I'm
not living them myself
so as they say in in recovery
you can't transmit something you haven't
got so if I want to transmit a certain
vibration I have to carry that vibration
otherwise it's a lie so that's something
I do spend a lot of time thinking about
and and that does become challenging
because if you read finding ultra it
looks like I'm training all the time
well I'm almost 53 right now and this
podcast is almost a full-time job and
I'm traveling for speaking engagements
I'm doing lots of different things and I
stay connected to endurance and fitness
and I get out there almost every single
day and do something but I'm not the
physical specimen that you see on the
cover of that book anymore like I can't
I can't walk around looking like that
all the time and do all these other
things that I'm doing so that's you know
if I try to hold myself to that like
then I'm living an unsustainable life so
you know I have to let go of that and
try to be a healthy person who's
connected to the things that I love and
still is involved in endurance sports
but not be in it for the kind of
performance level that you know I was I
was reaching for my forties and that's
okay and I'm honest about that and
transparent about that but sometimes I'm
like you know people think I'm like I
have I'm super ripped all the
and then you know I gonna win i go to i
go to the montana thing and and you know
we're surrounded by these elite ultra
marathoners and like i'm like i can't
keep up with these guys
like but just like let it go it's okay
so the calculus that i run in my mind
when it comes to how do i allocate my
time and invest my energy is less about
like how fast can i run or how far can i
run and more about like what is the best
way for me to impact the most number of
people in the most meaningful way yeah
and staying connected to being fit and
healthy is important but but if it means
i'm not having a conversation with you
or doing some event where i knew i can
you know i can move the needle in
people's lives then I'm gonna always opt
for that which means you know I can't be
spending 20 hours a week training and
like who cares if I do anymore like is
it really important like how far long I
can ride my bike like no yeah I think
maybe I'm projecting a little bit when
I'm asking this question because there's
an a feeling of I'm a people pleaser
when it comes to just about everything
and you and me both
yeah and when when people come up to you
there's a certain sense of living up to
their set of expectations whether it's
perceives or not and I always feel like
I'm always I'm always afraid that that
one interaction will they'll walk away
going oh he's not the person I thought
he and even when it comes to athletics
like this um you know a couple of
weekends ago when I had to drop out of
the Angeles Crest 100 that I was
training for I felt like I was letting
people down mm-hm and so it was a it was
a very difficult decision to to land on
finally but this is all I'm sure largely
imagined yeah of course it is like
you're that's a very codependent mindset
and I get it like I I understand exactly
what you're saying like if I'm not
racing anymore
am I even relevant in this conversation
and I do have a like a fraud complex
when I'm surrounded by like
damnit like ultrarunner like when you're
when you're with Timmy Olsen it's like
come on man like I'm not I'm not
you know like Who am I you know this it
doesn't it doesn't yeah I can't I can't
purport to be somebody who's even in the
same sport or league as this individual
so I just I'm honest about it like
that's all I can do and I can't get
caught up in other people's expectations
or their ideas of who I who they want me
to be or should be you just have to be
yourself and in terms of like
opportunities like you deciding not to
do Angeles Crest you know a little
mantra that's been helpful for me is
understanding that an invitation is not
a subpoena you know like if you're if
you're like you know just because you
have an opportunity to do this cool
thing and you associate it with like who
you are that doesn't mean that you have
to do it or you're gonna let all these
people down it's your life you had a
race yet to cancel on right yeah so and
I made public announcements about this
like I was meant to participate in this
ultra endurance triathlon double Ironman
distance thing with my coach Chris
health though that that is going down in
Qatar in November and I hadn't raced in
two years and I was excited about this
challenge because I felt like okay it's
time and this seems really cool like a
fun adventure it's not really a race but
like what an amazing opportunity to go
to this part of the world and see what
it's like outside a big city like
incredible once-in-a-lifetime thing but
over the last several months my life has
been so full of opportunities and
obligations things that I welcomed into
my life that I think are important and
you know part of who I am and what I do
that training like I take an adventure
like that seriously like I can't
half-ass my way towards that like I
can't fake it like I have to put in some
serious hours and those hours became
more and more difficult to justify and
rationalize because they were taking
away from other opportunities that I had
judged at this moment in my life needed
more prioritization and the challenge I
had was
letting go of okay I said I was going to
do this thing but now it's just not
practical and also the the like the self
judgment like oh I failed or I've let
myself down or other people down and
also coming to terms with the fact that
like I don't want to feel guilty about
saying yes to doing certain things that
I've worked really you know from those
days when we couldn't pay for our
garbage to get picked up to now being
invited to do certain cool like hey go
come to Telluride and like talk at this
amazing event like I'm sure you're
turning down so you're accept oh yeah I
turned down tons of stuff but there are
certain things I want to say yes to and
I want to feel bad about that because I
said I was going to do a race that in
the greater context of my life I'm not
sure is really the most important
receivership for my time and energy
right now so I've kind of had to let
that go until it was your last race then
there's like two years ago that's two
years ago years ago feel like that was
just weeks ago yeah yeah I know this is
what getting old is continues to
accelerate though oh man yeah there's a
lot of things about getting older that
I'm not I'm still trying to adjust to it
adapt to something else when I think
about when I think about rich role is I
think about you as very much a giver you
I know you were certain podcasts where
you will share the contact information
of certain guests like a Casey nice
tattoo Louis house or you know like I'm
sure the examples of that and I'm sure
David Coggins to somebody that you
probably get hit up on constantly you
know there and there's guys like Gary
Vee who talks about giving without
expectations right tell me how that's on
the other side of it enriched your life
and and what you derive from it even
with me personally I can attest to you
sharing you know when I launched my
patreon account when I launched my
podcast you shared it out and you wrote
very nice things which I very much
appreciate selling lives so my mentality
is like any chance I get to support rich
I'm going to you know and and I'm sure
that's not something that you expect but
I
think human beings inherently are giving
creatures and where we feel our best
when we give I think so I mean if you
want to experience a life of purpose and
fulfillment give of yourself freely and
be of service it's really as simple as
that the problem is that we're in a
culture that that looks at the world as
a zero-sum game yeah and and a culture
that looks at relationships as
transactional and that's a huge problem
you know and and what I've learned and I
learned this in 12-step like this is
what I've learned through sobriety give
of yourself freely and you will be
repaid you know in exponentially so even
if you do it for selfish reasons like oh
I'm gonna get repaid exponentially like
it still works but I think when you're
when you're of when you live your life
with an open heart and you live your
life free of expectations from others
and you just give of yourself without
expectation that is that's the secret
that's the secret to being happy into
being fulfilled it's a path towards
letting go of resentments of looking at
the world like it's a competition like
for me to share your patreon how does
that negatively impact me like of course
I would do that like you create great
content to the extent that I can broaden
your audience by helping you know expose
your work to more people like that makes
me feel good why would that be like oh
how would that be a negative for me and
the beauty in a macro sense is a grand
experiment in that because it's not
about me you know it's about the guests
it's like I curate the experience but
it's all about me making a decision to
have a certain person on because I think
that this person's voice has merit and I
want to learn more and I want to share
that person's perspective with you and
that's it and to the extent that they're
met like I want to amplify all of these
people and as a result of that then my
own signal gets amplified but really
that's not the focus the focus is like
the spotlight is on the guests
and the more I do that the more the
audience benefits and fundamentally I
think the more the audience trust me and
that really kind of institutionalizes
what I'm doing well with all that being
said how difficult is it for you to turn
people down because I'm sure you get
head up all the time like hey retro I
have a book coming out let me be on our
show well especially especially when
you're a people pleaser like I want to
have everybody on and and I have to
remember that an invitation is not a
subpoena like yeah it creates that's the
you know I'm very conflict averse which
is why fundamentally I you know should
have never been a lawyer because being a
lawyer means thriving on on that kind of
thing so I don't want to disappoint
anyone
and I think everybody has an interesting
story we're sharing on some level and
now with with the corporatization of
podcasting you see all of these sub
industries creeping up around podcasting
and supporting it and one of those is
the PR machine now everybody realizes
like Oh podcasts are the way you sell
books so I'm on the list of all the
publishing houses so I get all the
galleys in the mail before these books
come out so I literally get like a dozen
books a week and a mail I get a constant
stream of email pitches for people to be
guests too many for me to even respond
to and so the way that I deal with that
is to remember that my allegiance is not
to these individuals but to the audience
like what what do I think is in the best
interest of the audience I have to put
that first and I've also learned that to
trust my gut on guests like I know it
when I see it like I know that this
person will be appropriate or right as
opposed to a bunch of people saying oh
man you got to interview this person
they're incredible and if I'm not
feeling it yeah I've made this mistake
in the past like yeah I don't really
feel it but everyone seems to think I
should do this so I do it and generally
it's okay but it's not great you know
and if you're doing hundreds and
hundreds of these they're not all going
to be
amazing and you learn certain things
along the way and one of the most
important is that I need to learn how I
need to learn to trust my instincts and
even when I do it doesn't mean it lives
up to my own expectations that I set for
it but more often than not it's the
right it's the right thing
can you single out by name the people
with disappointment how do you make your
money hmm that's the question my parents
want to know the answer to they're still
confused you and your parents and I have
been exchanging oh yeah yeah yeah help
help my dad calm down yeah so I make I
make money in a variety of different
ways I make money through podcast
advertising so I do two or three live
reads on the show I do six shows a month
and that is now probably the most robust
income that I make and the most
predictable so I have that and then we
have our meal planner digital product
which I'm super proud of it provides a
great service to people that are really
learning how to dial and their diets
very affordable so that provides monthly
income to us as well speaking
engagements provide income the retreats
that Julie and I do together provide
income book sales provide income what
else I mean there's a smattering of
other things
I've got a small patreon that provides
income Amazon Associates provide some
income what else I mean it's a speaking
I forget speaking engagements yeah
retreats what else oh now doing you know
now stepping into some broader product
sponsorship opportunities so that's
that's a new experience and now I'm I
got this live event that I'm doing at
the end of September yeah that's gonna
be a new experience and the idea behind
that is setting up a tour for 2020 like
a multi-city tour for the podcast well I
definitely want to touch upon that a
couple more questions because I feel
like me be remiss if we didn't talk
about nutrition which I'm sure you get
hit up about constantly but I'm more
about your perspective on how you see
plant-based nutrition burgers sausages
things like that right are a little more
apt to being a gateway food if you will
right and having it go a little more
mainstream we see Carl's jr. adopting
the plant-based burger we see del Taco I
think has a plant-based option I'm like
I imagine if [ __ ] in and out had a
beyond me patty like a secret menu where
you can get that in like vegenaise like
they crush it yeah you know and so I'm
just looking at it from afar and as I've
you know talked to people like TK Pollan
who has plant flower venture that he's
launching and supporting all these other
startups like where do you see this
going I see it continuing to grow
I mean it's exploding right now it's
kind of an amazing thing I mean I've
been plant-based now for 12 years and
you know look there's people out there
they've been client base for 40 years so
it's not like you know I'm a super og
but the extent of change and growth that
I've seen in the last decade is
astronomical so this is more than a
trendy diet of the month we're seeing a
progressive movement of mainstream
culture towards a more plant centric
diet and that is a function I think of a
few things a we're in the midst of a
cataclysmic cataclysmic health care
crisis where people are never have never
been more obese or diabetic than they
ever have been one out of every three
Americans dies of some form of heart
disease so crazy incidence of poor
health in America secondarily we're also
experiencing an unprecedented
environmental crisis and by all accounts
the impact of animal agriculture
industrialized animal agriculture on our
environment is extremely deleterious by
some accounts equal to if not more
impactful than the transportation sector
so to the extent that we can reduce or
eradicate
that kind of animal intensive farming
has a benefit for planetary well-being
and thirdly I think human beings are
innately are innately compassionate
nobody likes the idea of killing an
animal for their food and the more you
learn about the way these animals are
raised and and slaughtered for our food
system the more upsetting it is you know
and I think in an Internet culture we
we're now we now have more of that
information accessible than we did
before so more people are hip to what's
actually going on so we have these
technologies now where they're able to
create meat and dairy analogues in a way
that are healthier than what's available
in certain respect in certain cases more
environmentally sustainable than their
animal counterparts and certainly
sparing these animals lives and they
taste good so it tastes like [ __ ] I mean
so yeah it used to be
you eat these hockey pucks that taste
terrible or whatever it is they're
horrible but now they figured out how to
make them taste if not exactly the same
a different version of that that that is
quite palatable and so I think all
things being even now you have people
saying sure like why you know why do I
need to like participate in these things
that don't align with my values when I
can eat this other thing that actually
tastes pretty damn good and I think
that's super exciting and that's why the
market caps that's why you know when
beyond meat went public now its stock is
through the roof the market caps on on
you know plant-based dairy alternatives
are insanely high there's so much money
pouring into this everyone from yeah you
mentioned TK Pilon but we have you know
we have Bill Gates and Google Ventures
and like the biggest venture funds and
the biggest and you know investors in
the world are pouring into this space
because they see the long-term value of
how this is going to shift how we think
about food now my belief is that eating
plant foods
closest to their natural state is the
most ideal variety to do this
so it's not as if you know eating some
of these plant-based burgers is some
kind of health panacea like they aren't
necessary no junk food but yeah yeah if
you go like now impossible foods just
announced that they're gonna be in
Burger King's nationwide seven like
7,000 plus Burger Kings like that's
incredible it's incredible that that's
happening that you can provide this
alternative to the whopper to millions
and millions of people what is the long
term impact of that it's all good you
know that doesn't mean that I'm
necessarily the customer for that
because I'm not the customer is the
super hardcore meat-eater that doesn't
think that anything can match up and if
you can meet them where they're at and
satisfied that person that's a massive
win and so I'm super encouraged and
excited about all this I mean I've had
Ethan Brown the CEO and founder of
beyond meat has been on the podcast I
just had Pat Brown who was the founder
and CEO of impossible foods on the show
that episode hasn't gone up yet it won't
go up for a little while but you know I
think the work that they're doing is is
transformative and incredible and should
be celebrated yeah it's just giving
people a choice yeah and I'll turn it if
that is on par with what they can get
without the deleterious effects of
absolutely the environment which i think
is really cool I be I have a couple of
patreon questions I want to get to one
of them one of whose names you might
recognize
Jason coop your new buddy well you're a
paste and crude Dean Karnazes at bad
water
he wrote rich has a large and dedicated
platform of listeners he's also
principled particularly in the areas of
nutrition wellness and the environment
similar to any journalist I'm curious if
he has any views or if he views his role
as an influencer hostess etc as having
some type of responsibility to
perpetuate those principles particularly
in choosing guests that so we talked
about this briefly but maybe if you
wanted to expand on your right what's up
chase well particularly in choosing
guests that might have differing
principles or in asking guests questions
that bring their differences to the
forefront yeah it's a great question I
think you know I I think about this a
lot and I'm not sure that I have
absolute clarity on it and I think it's
a really important question
so you're poking by the way is that you
oh I do I do it yeah I'm the only one
who makes the decision about who comes
on the show I mean it you know I'll take
like my business partner Greg will be
like let's have this person and you know
I'll be like okay cool like but most of
it most of the time you know I'm the one
making that decision I think in the
context of of like diet and nutrition
emotions run so hot in this area and I
do have a very clear point of view on
this I'm pretty convicted in my
perspective about what I think is right
and ethical and all that all of that and
that's well documented so what is my
responsibility to have somebody on who
has a different point of view and I
don't know the answer to that should I
have a carnivore on so that I could have
a debate with that person about what a
better way to eat is I don't know that
that's really productive nor do I feel
like that's my responsibility you know
what I mean everyone wants to see these
people fight with each other or have
some kind of push back on each other's
lives to what end
well maybe having somebody on like that
would help shape their point of view or
shape their own like this is how I would
respond to questions about you know when
people have diets that contradict my own
the plant-based diet I don't know yeah I
mean I've done it I've been a guest on
shows where it's sort of been like that
I mean look I've had Vinny tour to
Russia on my show many you know in the
early days Vinny's a friend of mine we
have very different perspectives on
nutrition Ben Greenfield is a friend of
mine he's been on the show we have
different views on nutrition I've had
over the years I've had people like that
on the show but should I have a doctor
on who has a completely radical
radically different perspective
on diet nutrition than ideal why so that
so that he can assail me and I can
assail him I don't know you know I think
I'm arrived at this point where where I
know it works for me I feel really good
about it
I feel physically healthy I believe in
this lifestyle but I'm not interested in
the acrimony and the debate and the
clickbait t nature yeah pitting people
against each other plus I'm not a
scientist I'm not gonna I'm not steeped
in the latest studies and all of that
like I'm just living my life and and I'm
in exam I self as an example of a way of
living and if you're interested in
asking me about it I'm happy to share it
with you but I'm not here to tell you
how to live or not live which people
appreciate about you you're not dogmatic
about any one way of living like these
are these aren't my virtues they should
be yours too Liz McCutchen who was also
a patreon supporter either way I don't
know if I answered Jason's questions
Jason will be fine either way
he's off in the mountain somewhere
pacing its wife in June of 2017 I was
driving my car listening to the rich
world podcast it was an episode with
dr.neil barnard is that how you say his
name mm-hmm at the time I was vegetarian
and the only thing animal-based in my
diet was cheese for some reason I wasn't
willing to give it up until dr. Barnard
told the story that I will not that I
will never forget it was about a baby
cow being taken from its mother up until
that point I thought eating cheese
wasn't hurting the animals as a mother
it really hit home and I saw it at that
very moment I made the decision that
would be vegan and I haven't had cheese
since I have always been meaning to
email rich about this but never did his
podcast has had a big influence on me
I just wanted him to know that I mean
you must get count yeah I appreciate
that
she shouldn't worry about emailing me
though she should email Neil he's the
one who told the story and I think that
she would really enjoy Julie's new vegan
cheese creation her vegan cheese was
insane its insanely good right I'm not
just saying that because I'm
in the presence of her husband it was
insane
you guys her her version of mozzarella
in particular when she made the right
caprese salad was out of this world
yeah so we were in Montana Billy and I
together at this this jaybird event and
Julie oversaw the menu but she also
brought up a whole bunch of her
plant-based cheeses for everybody to
enjoy yeah so if I had options like that
in the store and restaurants I would try
it let's go a little more speed round
before we wrap this up I'm curious about
Sunday service Kanye West you shared a
very cryptic video of you attending yeah
was that like it was amazing I was I was
so confused I got a like a lot of
criticism for that because I yes yeah
okay because yeah I got a lot of
criticism for even attending that so the
story is can tell a little bit of a
longer version of it cuz it's pretty
cool so there's a trail near my house
and I was running out there one Sunday
many months ago four or five months ago
maybe Sunday morning and Mathon point in
the trail where I have to make this
right-hand turn and therewithal all
these people up there and I was told
there was a security guard who told me I
couldn't go any further I had to turn
around and I've been running on this
trail for years like what do you mean I
can't go in here who are you
security guard the middle of nowhere on
this trail I was like alright and I
turned around and as I was running back
I started to hear gospel music I was
like oh this is where Kanye does his
Sunday service so I was like man that is
cool like I could hear it and it just
sounded amazing and I was like I got I
gotta figure out a way to get I got to
see this like how is this gonna work
like I got to figure out a way to get in
on this is so cool it's happening in
like my backyard like what an incredible
thing and it was one of those things I
can't remember whether I shared this
with you I had this experience a couple
times before in my life where I just
make this decision like oh that's gonna
happen like I'm going to
I'm gonna I'm gonna pick your minding
yeah I'm gonna be at that thing like
there's no doubt about it but then I
didn't do it it's not like it did
anything about it I did nothing about it
I just decided that somehow I was gonna
be at that thing at some point oh god oh
we believe fast forward to it what does
that book that will book about the yeah
hey listen man I'm a pretty so fast
forward like maybe like two weeks later
our friend Mel Nahas who's an incredible
person she produces all our
international retreats she or actually
it was like the following I did a little
Instagram story like you know over her
herd in the hills Kanye Sunday service
so Mel texts me and she's like where
exactly is that happening like where in
that trail so I i screenshot a map and
drew a little like dot like here's
exactly where that thing is happening
she's like okay I'm gonna have my
birthday party there I was like okay how
are you gonna do that like who do you
even call like how do you even figure
that out she's like don't worry about it
she's a very capable person like when
she sets her mind to something she
figures that out it turns out she's from
Western Australia originally and it
turns out the park ranger in this state
park area yeah is also from Perth where
she's from and they already knew each
other somehow and she figured out how to
like rent this little space in the
middle of this park to have like a
dinner for her birthday party so a
couple weeks later we have this dinner
and right in the middle of this park
where Kanye does the Sunday service he
built like this like raised mound of
like dirt and arounded are these big
boulders and Mel had strong like like
those Edison lamps you know like picnic
lights out there and and like a really
long table and brought like a DJ and had
the whole thing catered and it was at
sunset there's like 30 or 40 of us up
here and it was beautiful it was like a
beautiful night and I was like I can't
believe you pulled this off now like how
did you make this work and you got to
drive up this weird dirt road and part
like it you can't find it ordinarily
like you have to really know where
you're going so we're up there enjoying
this dinner and
of course you can't help but talk about
Sunday service because this is where it
happens is the exact place where it's
happening so I'm talking about how like
oh yeah I was running and I saw this
going on it's pretty cool and then a
buddy of mine who was sitting next to me
see there's a there's like an
african-american dude and he's like kind
of approaching our group from a distance
it's getting kind of dark at this point
he goes oh yeah there's Kanye right
there and we're like ah hahahaha but as
the guy got closer and closer we're like
oh my god that is Kanye like Kanye
literally out of nowhere just walked up
on our group so I was like Julie come on
we gotta go meet him so Mel and Julie
and I went up and we greeted him and we
had this amazing conversation with Kanye
West he's like he was with his daughter
his youngest daughter's little daughter
and and she had a friend and he just
walked up there so because that his
daughter wanted to play on the boulders
on the rocks and he lives not that far
away so it was completely random he
didn't know that anything was going on
up there and we just started talking him
about Sunday service and what he was
doing and what his dream for it was and
what his plan was and how he you know
really wanted to he was frustrated
because he was having trouble getting
people to kind of buy into this larger
vision that he had for it and he's
somebody who like it's very clear I'm
like what he's trying to manifest and
works with a lot of different people and
it was just I mean it was amazing like
it was like it was super cool to like
meet this guy and that Coleman like he
know we exchange contact information
he's like you should come to the thing
and so like sure enough like the next
Sunday we were there at Sunday service
like it just it happened like it just
unfolded like so seamlessly and
naturally so yeah Julie and I and Mel
went up we got to see it and what I saw
was a group of incredibly talented
musicians just doing something that they
loved and sharing it for the world it's
it's free there's no II wasn't charging
anything for it in fact
Kanye's underwriting the whole thing is
costing him a lot of money to put this
thing on it just he wants to do more
conscious creative things and put them
out into the world and I think that's
something to be really celebrated and I
thought it was like a remarkable
experience because I have no doubt that
a year from now two years from now when
he really figures out what he wants us
to be it'll end up scaling into
something much larger but to be present
at its origin when there's just
literally I mean I don't know there
weren't that many people there you know
to watch this thing go down was really
it was really a special thing so
regardless of you know Kanye's political
affiliations or anything like that I
mean they I think it goes back to where
we opened this conversation which is
about radical compassion and non
judgement it's like just because I go to
Kanye Sunday service doesn't mean that
I'm endorsing his political views I'm
trying to celebrate this aspect of his
creative voice that I think has merit
and is something that we should all want
in the world yeah the fact that we have
this two-party system which I'm opposed
to and you're essentially boiled down to
you know one person or the other and you
make a choice doesn't mean you're all of
a sudden this Trump supporter or Hillary
supporter and you get painted with this
broad paintbrush and I think Tania was
unfairly ostracize for that especially
within his own community where maybe
that's a little more understandable but
anyway my follow-up question was gonna
be who's the most famous person in your
contact list yeah I guess I got my
answer
well is there any is there anyone more
famous than Kanye period yeah is there I
mean there's cool
like one of the things and I don't
really talk about this much and I don't
know that I want to get into specifics
but one of the cool sort of benefits of
doing what I do is you get contacted by
really cool people who asked for advice
or want your help or whatever so I kind
of quietly you know sort of not mentors
too strong of a word but like I you know
I I I serve as counsel to people sort of
anonymously and quietly behind the
scenes to some pretty cool
interesting people that all I'm gonna
choose to not name but any NBA or NFL
players a couple yeah a couple really
yeah he told me offline yeah I'll tell
you yeah and that's really cool and and
I you know that's I don't do that for
gratification like I just it's an honor
to be able to you know try to contribute
to other people's loss yeah in that way
any opportunities or chance prospect of
Kanye coming on your show oh I don't
know okay I can't say I know I know him
well enough for that and I know that
there was talk about him going on Rogen
and then it didn't happen so I'm not
sure like if he's not gonna go on Rogen
and I don't know these things are you
know relationships like that are
delicate you know and and like I said
like I don't want my relationship with
people to be transactional so I you know
I'm more interested in getting to know
people over the long run and if it's
appropriate at some point in time for
them where they feel comfortable sharing
their message and coming on that's fine
but you know to meet someone like that
and then immediately hit them up to come
on up on right yeah it's like it's just
not it's it's not cool yeah it's a such
a la thing to do glad you didn't fight
into that
what about podcasts who do you listen to
right now that's always changing and
evolving like I love you know exploring
new voices and things that are out there
but I have my favorites like I like you
know some of this some of my stock and
trade I don't listen to a lot of
podcasts that are in my kind of similar
space because it feels like homework
unless I have a guest coming on and
they've been on one of those shows don't
research yeah I love let's do a lot of
like tech and media stuff mmm like a
movie stuff I like Bill Simmons I'm not
a huge sports guy but I love when he
does culture stuff yeah LOL i love his
conversations with Chuck Klosterman like
things like that and I like a lot of the
ringer shows like the rewatchable is in
the big picture really yeah I love those
amazing I just listened to the town and
yeah it was great
yeah and I was like and then I went I
told you I floated flew to Nashville and
I was desperately before getting on my
plane trying to figure out how I could
download the town and watch it yes yeah
that's exactly what I did
I downloaded it I was like I'm gonna
save this podcast and then we watch it
before I listen to it again I just think
they're really smart like their takes on
things are super intelligent and well
thought-out like I just I really enjoy
that stuff I like reply all I think it's
really good I like did you listen to
startup I was like you know you yes some
of it I mean I listened to the first
episode like I can just pull up your
startup was really what had me thinking
about I did a narrative podcast recently
or yeah I guess it's called a narrative
podcast and it was an interesting
experiment to do as a storyteller just
naturally in general and ice in a lot of
ways it was a lot easier than creating
film because he could just fill in the
gaps with their own voice so it was an
interesting experiment something that I
may I think you should explore that
because you're a very good storyteller
and I think the heat in podcasting is
all over is all around really tight high
production value story [ __ ] work it's
an incredible amount of work and it
takes teams of people and it takes
patience in time like you know on my
list of course revisionist history I
mean nobody does it better than that why
haven't you had Malcom Gladwell yeah I'm
trying to get him on right now it's a
scheduling thing we've been going back
and forth
I think Dax Shepard is very good oh yeah
and I think you know when people ask me
like how did you learn how to talk to
people and interview people part of it
is doing a lot of depositions as a
lawyer but the bigger part is being in
12-step like you just you learn empathy
and you learn storytelling and
vulnerability and you can't help but
become fascinated by other people's
stories and it's a think people that are
in a a art can become natural podcast so
and you know that definitely comes
across for me and Dax and I just I
finally was saying really really good if
that is not an answer that I would would
have expected totally Wow
totally Russell Brand under the skin sam
harris making sense i like Kara Swisher
so I listen to reco decode and pivot
yeah he'll yeah she was that's right
Neil Strauss did a series called to live
and die
talking to your storytelling the what is
that wrote the truth and the pickup book
yeah he did
I know Neal quite well he's an amazingly
talented person to live in Dalian la is
great
the rob cast with Rob Bell Marc Maron
old school gotta left Marc Maron do you
yeah I do you know you know like you
give it's I don't like yes dependent
just like Rogen is to me I think depends
on the guest like yeah Rogen's the same
thing like I don't listen to every rope
yeah so but what they're all like three
hours to you have to really want to
commit and I'm sorry at the same time I
don't want to hear about what you know
dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson thinks about
this MMA Friday like he came over the
board well it is the Joe Rogan
experience it is a Joe Rogan exam
I like Pete Holmes show you made it
weird he was on your podcast recently
yeah he's cool you know sometimes I
listen to some political stuff pod save
America and Bill Maher Radiolab you know
I pick and choose in my space like I'll
pick and choose occasionally episodes
from shows like Tim Ferriss or what she
and Parrish is doing with the knowledge
project right now I think it's really
interesting somebody who knows Tim very
well the good life pro he's only told me
that your interview with Tim was one of
the most revealing like when you can
have a guest like that that's clearly
done the rounds and says your podcast
stands out that must mean something a
little extra special I appreciate that
yeah you know I think part of that was
informed by Tim being in a in a place at
that period of time where he was open to
being more vulnerable than he usually is
but I was really glad to be able to well
we also said like you know get some
stuff out of him that I think you know
his audience appreciate it and and you
know really has a has a hunger for yeah
they want to know who this guy is you
know who they followed for so long and
have gotten so much benefit from yeah
I hate the term bucket list guests but
what about when it comes to running I
know you've landed like the moby-dick of
endurance athletes and something like
Kilian and even desi is there somebody
in running specifically that you're
eyeballing maybe we can put it out there
hmm
so many and running specifically yeah I
mean I think well I would I would
preface this answer by saying this which
is I think interviewing athletes is
difficult and it's because I've put a
lot of thought into this I've talked to
a I talked to Michael Gervais about it
at length as well I think it's because
for the most part athletes are doers
more than thinkers they're not
necessarily you know they're not
professional conversationalist and and
sometimes they're they're not as
introspective as you would like which
makes for a challenging podcast so when
I think about athletes that I want to
have on the show it's as much about
their accomplishments as it is about
other things in their life that I think
make them interesting and more
compelling human beings and and guess
and that's hard you know and sometimes
you don't know until you have them on
but I know like when I have an athlete
on sometimes it requires a little more
heavy lifting host wise than it does
look if you have Pete Holmes on like you
have to do anything
question yes so right like it just takes
on the life of its own and that's not
usually the case with an athlete look
I'd like to have Courtney doll Walter on
like she would be amazing you know all
these people like I don't know all of
them like people that I want I like you
know I want more women athletes on I
think it's important
I mean she's killing it and crushing it
and doing so many interesting things
I'm having Lauren flood Lauren Fleshman
on soon so I'm looking forward to that I
mean who else in the running space I
mean I'd like to have Justin Grunwald on
you know and I know you just out of mana
I wanted to ask you about how that
experience was he's alright that's an
amazing story yeah so that's a perfect
example of somebody who's got who's an
incredible runner but also has you know
there's there's there's a life and a
story a powerful powerful story that
exists outside of simply being a runner
yeah you're not asking about temple what
yeah exactly that's I'm the same way and
I think somebody who's been on my list
is mad to fly oh yeah yeah and I relate
to his story because I'm an immigrant
myself came to this country when I was
young and to a degree I think that story
hasn't been told that was at least in
podcast form a couple more to blow
through and then I do I want to be
conscious of your time do you have a
hundred-mile race in your future in my
future yeah maybe I don't know nothing
nothing
right now okay I just got done telling
you why I had to like not do this other
race oh wow hundred miles like yeah
that's that's no joke man like I don't
you know I don't like I take that stuff
super seriously like I know you do you
can't be you can't just flirt with that
stuff like if you're gonna do it you
have to really like you owe it to the
race and to the other competitors and
all those people to like really take it
seriously tell me about your biggest
podcasting gaff biggest podcasting gaff
has there been a time like yet you
didn't hit record or you know I've had a
couple of those I think maybe in seven
years
two maybe three times the recording got
messed up and I couldn't air one time
like it just didn't record at all
another time the card filled up but it
still sounded like it was happening and
so I only got like two-thirds of the
conversation because it's still
recording now because the record is on
your side okay it's definitely recording
yeah I've had a couple of those are you
seeing levels too
we are good dude don't wait now you got
me paranoid yes I've had a couple of
those which are super immature I know
that was one that you did it we do like
on the spot yes I think that was because
of that yeah and then I've had a couple
I don't know if gaff is the right word
for it but I've had a couple instances
in which I interviewed somebody and then
it just wasn't it didn't rise to the
quality level but I felt like I could
share it with the onions and so I'd
never saw the light of day and as a
people pleaser that's a tricky thing
yeah if somebody comes it gives their
time and it's just flat and you're like
can't do it how did you break the news
which is you're pointed at that
potential technical technical issue I
don't remember how I handled it probably
not well that's not where I excel I want
to pretend like it doesn't exist but
that goes back to remembering that the
allegiance is to the audience and not to
the guests 100% 100% what about your
musical tastes something that I feel
like you don't really talk about too
much but I'm curious about came up that
in my conversation with Jeff Gordon err
I'm like an alt rock dude you know it's
like that thing you you the music you
love is the music that was most
impressionable to you when you were like
18 to 23 mm-hmm so for me it's like REM
wasn't everything REM is probably my
favorite band and still is like I still
listen to it all the time you know well
then live at the Greek Theatre so yeah
like Michael Stipe is a dream guest for
me to have on like that guy had a piece
impact on my life as a young person so
what's he up to now he was just on you
know goop started this new podcast
called goop fellas uh-huh and the hosts
are friends of mine and Seamus Mullen
who's been a guest on this show as a
chef who's friends with Mike all they
had Michael on and it was interesting it
was all about like his wellness routines
you know and he's actually back in the
studio he's recording some solo stuff
and he's published a couple books of
photography you know he's pretty
movies over the years like he's been you
know has been sort of a creative person
in different respects podcasts reinforce
your desire to have a monk yeah I think
so thank you so what a few ways yeah
yeah super interesting guy you know yeah
of course like he's lived an incredible
life like you know unbelievably dynamic
person so yeah like you know listen the
cure dismiss REM English bead general
public madness yeah you know that kind
of era of music is still my favorite
music but I would say you know radiating
a Radiohead for sure like I'm not I'm
not I've never been able to really
connect with hip hop my 15 year old
daughter is just like a fanatic about
super hardcore hip-hop we should at
least brush up on your Kanye adjusting I
know yeah it's like I don't you know
it's weird like I don't listen to it
it's also funny because I have these
hardcore straightedge pump dudes on that
podcast cuz I love all these guys but I
have difficulty connecting with that
music
yeah to like it's not my thing I respect
what they do but like I'm I'm stuck I'm
stuck in the late 80s brother I'm the
same way too I at some point that desire
to know I mean every now and again I'll
cherry-pick but yeah I am somewhat that
said in the early aughts
maybe they may be bleeding over into the
90s a little bit yeah I mean look I you
know I try to stay hip to what's going
on but it still has to be rooted in
something that I understand and relate
to so you know for me I think aspects of
hip-hop are a bit of a bridge too far
but like I love lore and like I love
Billy Eilish I think what Billy is
incredible yeah you know and that's
something that I can share with my
youngest daughter because she loves
Billy Eilish and I was like I get it
like this this this is this is like a
once in a generation talent you know so
I try to you know be on top of what's
going on well objectively I can tell you
I feel like I can say most modern
hip-hop this crap but there are some
still skillful storytellers out there
yeah and if you know like Kendrick Lamar
or Jay Cole and have you seen the
Defiant once the HBO documentaries did
but that was just nothing short of
brilliance I won't make a poem yeah okay
all right let's talk about the live
event because I definitely want to
promote that I feel like this you know
you venturing more into at least
intentionally into the public speaking
realm is just a natural progression to
you're still evolving story
mm-hm and so yeah the whole adage about
how people would rather be the person in
the coffin than the one actually
delivering the eulogy like you've had
enough practice by now but I'm I'm
really curious about how you decided to
go forward with something like this at
the scale in which you're intending on
delivering this first show at the
Wilshire Ebell theatre which is gorgeous
1,200 seat theater but you know you're
going all-in you're not doing this
you're not kind of like dipping your
toes into this realm so yeah it's about
that bro say yeah it's a it's a big step
I really you know have this vision of
going on the road with the podcast and
doing a multi-city tour you know part of
it is informed by the fact that I live
in a relatively remote yes that were in
LA but like I kind of live in a remote
area and I spend most of my time at home
and I produce the podcast and do what I
do but it's not unless I travel or I'm
in airports that I meet people or
connect with people that are that are
you know fans are impacted by the work
that I do and I like that connection and
I want it to deepen that connection and
I think doing live events is a great
opportunity to create additional
community around these ideas that I feel
are important so that's part of it and
it just sounds like a blast
like let's go on the road with the
podcast like super fun right so the
first phase of that is producing an
event in LA and just crushing it like
rocking it out to establish like hey the
audience is there
and to engender confidence in the venue
Booker's across the country that we can
fill a room of that size so it's a big
venue 1,200 seats it's no joke were over
half sold out at this point we're what
is it August 9th or August 8th August
9th today and we still have six weeks to
go so I'm confident that we're gonna
sell it out yeah super exciting and it's
gonna be a live version of the podcast
of course but also I'm building in other
kind of entertainment elements so that
it is a standalone experience that is
tailored for you know being there in
person so I'm gonna be making
announcements fairly soon about who the
special guest is and some of the other
things that we're gonna do and so you're
not going to do a Letterman style and
surprise people up there I thought about
that I mean I think that's what doc
Shepherd does like he just he doesn't
tell anyone and then even surprises them
but I you know and I think it depends on
who there's a couple people were looking
at for the special guests like you know
certain people don't want you leveraging
their name just to sell tickets like and
I can understand that it's probably part
of the reason why Dex does it the way he
does so we're just trying to figure out
as we go but more will be revealed but
yeah the event is September 27th Friday
Wilshire Ebell theatre beautiful
historic one of those old-school la
theaters 1,200 seats and yeah madame
pumped it's gonna be cool and the idea
is we're gonna you know we're going to
be able to capture all of that and then
if appropriate like also share that on
the podcast so it's sort of like we do
two things at once but that in-person
experience is just it's something unique
and special and something I want to have
more of it makes all the sense in the
world to see you evolve into the space
and what about video are you gonna do
any video production lawyer yeah we're
gonna we're looking into that as well
like we got to get we have to solicit
the approval of the venue and all of
that it's like complicated there's
certain things like we can't do without
huge additional expense and you know
we're like this is all new to me so
we're like kind of learning the
the rules of the road as we go and so I
don't have answers to everything because
it's still just dating and and coming to
you know it's it's not quite completely
clear how it's gonna go yet oh I'm super
pumped for you I think it'll be an
amazing evening I bought my tickets
yesterday appreciate other friends
encourage them to come along with me I
have to say like I want to publicly
acknowledge you and thank you cuz every
time I do any kind of live thing or
whatever like you're always you've
always showed up man I like and believe
me like I've noticed like it and that's
very meaningful to me I really
appreciate that you've been a huge
support to me from day one
yeah well look again this all goes full
circle just like you got Goggins his
name out there I think he's you know
like he's he was very instrumental in
your whole endurance journey and it's
cyclical in how you're helping people I
think you know like I want to do
whatever little part that I can do to
support you and everything that you have
going on so in that vein if any of my
listeners out there you're out of town
and you want to come to LA you've always
wanted to come to LA September is a
beautiful time and what we'll do is if
you can send me a screenshot of your
receipt we will try to organize
something the morning of it's a Friday
morning well so if you want to travel
from out of town and you want to escape
the humidity of the Midwest or wherever
you're coming from and you've always
wanted to go on a trail run and maybe
we'll do breakfast afterwards but yeah
definitely
send me like bring your family for
Christ's sake you know like make a whole
event out of it I'm sure like LA is a
beautiful place vacation too we have
beaches I live in Hermosa Beach we have
mountains we have awesome trails so
September October is the best time of
the yeah so we will organize that on the
side so to go to ritual calm I think you
have to click on appearance yeah if you
go to my website and click on the
appearances tab you'll see it I also if
you go to my Twitter its pin to the top
there and there's a direct link to
purchase tickets I have a couple final
questions and then we'll end the show
I want to know about the best and the
worst days of your life when I ask you
that question
what comes to mind the best in the worst
days are kind of the same you know that
my my my my experience is that these
these things that happen were in the
moment feel like the absolute worst
thing that could ever happen to you tend
to be the beginning of something new and
amazing and I think we judge these
experiences based on a lack of data like
we say this is bad this is good this is
not supposed to be happening to me I
can't believe this is happening to me on
what criteria are we making that
judgment call and I think when you
telescope out and you've lived you know
a little bit longer and you've had more
experiences in your life you begin to
recognize that those ebbs and flows and
those low moments are actually the
catalyst for the things that you know
end up being the best things in your
life so if I had to identify those low
moments it's like I set my new wife home
from our honeymoon and never saw her
again
yeah it's a pretty dark moment that's a
moment that I had to drink for almost an
entire year afterwards because I was so
emotionally devastated by it and yet now
looking back on it I understand her
perspective and I'm very grateful that
that occurred because she was able to
see what I couldn't in that moment which
is that we were ill suited for each
other and that I had a tremendous amount
of personal growth that I needed to
undergo before I could be in a healthy
relationship or you know not being able
to pay these bills like these these
moments where we're tested are what
develop and reveal character and give us
the resiliency in the fortitude to
engage in and conquer challenges later
in our life so you know I do my best to
try to reserve judgment on these things
and the more I can just be present with
what is
in a more Jedi mentality of not being
reactive and judgmental that I'm in a
position to make better better decisions
and if you want to make those judgment
calls much later that's fine I think
you're in a better position to do that
but let's not be so quick to attach
labels to these things that happen in
our lives I don't mean to put you on the
spot but when it comes to the matter
matters of the heart and health you've
had this incredible assortment of guests
on your show when it's all said and done
and if you want to then a cheesy like
Randy Pausch kind of way but in a way
sort of like if you wanted to pass along
certain key messages from these episodes
that you can pinpoint for Jaya - mathis
- your other boys or their guests that
come to mind episodes that come to mind
that you want to impart onto them like
these are the lessons that I really want
to ingrain and impart on to you it's
such a hard question to answer
you know I think in broad strokes you
know I don't know if I could identify
particular guess but in terms of ideas
let's go with ideas then you know the
idea that we're all more capable than we
allow ourselves to believe the idea that
the stories we tell ourselves about who
we are are merely that and are generally
false and that we have the power to
reframe those stories whatever whatever
childhood trauma that you endure and
like I'm not a perfect parent you have
the ability to heal and allow it to not
hamstring your growth the idea that you
can achieve what it is that you set out
to achieve in your life if you're
willing to work hard and tackle
obstacles I mean there's plenty of
podcasts with people that have faced and
overcome crazy crazy obstacles and have
done it through community and force of
will and all these various things the
idea that we are
more than our accomplishments and who we
think we are but that there is a force
greater than ourselves at work people
community people community faith
lifestyle practices that that are about
self care you know transcending this
culture that Corral's us into thinking
things like material success and
commercial success and social media
success and all of these things have
value
lowering tasted already learning how to
you know trust your instincts and
embrace your heart and follow that
having the courage to follow that path I
think are super more important and you
know translating some of these into real
life has been you know a journey as a
parent it's like I'm on this microphone
[Music]
encouraging people to you know figure
out what it is that's special about them
and bring expression to that well I have
to do that in how I parent my children
to I can't say that and then tell them
that they have to come you know go live
their life in a certain way I mean you
were in our the other side of our house
earlier and you see it's covered with
like I don't know a hundred pieces of
art that my 15 year old daughter has
been hanging all over the house over the
last couple days because she's in art
school and she's in her entrepreneurial
Flair has led her to produce this art
show with like six bands and like 20
artists and she's having all these kids
over here for you know an experience in
the next couple days and that's cool
like I can't tell her like no you can't
do this here like of course how can I
help you do that like this is what we're
this is what we're here to do how can we
how can we bring greater expression to
that which we think is most important in
our lives and that inspires us well in
that vein I wanted to end the show I
usually end on a note of gratitude but I
really was particularly impacted by this
chapter which I
may not have been in the original
version this isn't an excerpt for from
finding ultra and a chapter called
finding your song and I was hoping that
we can go out and end the show with you
reading a short little excerpt from it
sure from where it's highlighted and to
where the high school yeah this
definitely wasn't part of the original
version let's get one thing straight up
front not everyone aspires to be an
ultra endurance athlete I get that
moreover it's beyond the point because
that's my song the point is that you to
have a song to sing a song entirely
different from mine a song uniquely
yours and yours alone I don't know what
your song is perhaps you don't either if
that's the case don't despair in truth
most of us live our lives so
unconsciously so disconnected and
reflexive we never pause to even ask the
question let alone entertain its answer
if we do we are then quick to shun the
impulse as an embarrassing immature
indulgence a whimsical distraction from
truly important things like career and
Status I know because I've been there
but this is a tragic inversion of
priorities because of the search for
what makes your heart beat hardest and
fidelity to its fullest most devoted
expression is the very stuff of life
rooted deep in our souls and coursing
vigorously through our veins it is our
birthright it is our lifeblood and it is
our sustenance so to repress that urge
or worse yet deny its very existence is
to squander the extraordinary gift of
what it truly means to be human
Patrol thank you brother thank you my
friend
[Music]
are you guys that was the episode what
did you guys think hopefully hopefully
you learned something new about him and
got tremendous value rich is full of
wisdom life experience and I think he
has a lot to offer including his live
event coming up as we mentioned
September 27th Friday night in LA at the
beautiful beautiful 1,200 seat Wilshire
Ebell theatre if you're an out-of-towner
as I mentioned please visit la see him
live you will not be disappointed I know
the quality of work that rich really
prides himself on and so there's no
doubt that it will be a great show and
as I also mentioned if you screenshot
your receipt your ticket I'll try to
coordinate something the Friday morning
or that morning Friday morning and take
you out on a beautiful trail run here in
Los Angeles it's a great time to be a
runner in LA and you know maybe we can
go grab a bite to eat or something after
and I do want to clarify that by we it's
going to be me rich it's gonna be busy
setting this whole thing up me along
with possibly a couple of guides who are
native to LA what else what else what
else what else I am oh I wanted to give
a shout out to the people who are about
to run the Leadville 100 it is a week
that I had initially planned on trying
to attend but I think with upcoming
travel and everything I have going on
right now and including helping out at
our family business I could not could
not find a way to get out of it so my
apologies in advance I've so desperately
wanted to be there in person and just
kind of hang out and cheer everybody on
all almost 800 of you guys and it is a
it's just a beautiful place I love that
race I love that week and weekend
could not make it work so I do have some
friends and patreon supporters who will
be running it dreama Walton who's been
crushing it on her training runs and her
lead-up races so by the white dream
the most adorable daughter and Adi if
you want to follow her account look up
treatment Walton we actually met at
silver rush fifty two years ago and have
been buts ever since so thank you dream
and I know you will crush it
Andrew Pollard another patreon supporter
will also be racing the hundred mile
race and Mark hrabowski another friend
of mine who is coming from pancake flat
Chicago and will be running this race
but I have been seeing on a Strava that
he's out there early acclimating doing
some laps around turquoise like so my
best wishes to you buddy
I'm sure you will crush it and you have
a great strong woman
right behind you and Lisa so Lisa make
sure you get his ass out of winfield and
making sure he makes the cutoff times if
not exceeding it and finishing strong so
good luck to those people and everybody
running Leadville again wish I could be
there and after let me see I am going to
be in Utah next week for an event that
starts on Thursday but I think I'm gonna
head out a little bit early just outside
of Salt Lake City staying with a friend
I may try to hit up the Wasatch for a
couple of trail runs maybe do some
business in town in Salt Lake City so if
you're around I'm giving you that heads
up and then the week after I believe
that is chemin E the the famous UTMB
week and my plans are to fly out of LA
on Monday land on Tuesday and no nothing
official yet my plans are to get a
couple of podcasts maybe shoot some
video behind the scenes another one to
see it episode so stay tuned for that
but if you're gonna be in town and you
see me throughout town please do say
hello and I can I can tell you for sure
a lot of that time will be spent at
Moody's my favorite coffee place in
chemin e where they have amazing
cinnamon rolls actually maybe I should
edit that out because they do sell out
they only make one batch each morning
okay before we leave I want to give a
special shout out to
all the new $7 and up patreon supporters
who have joined since the last time we
spoke and let me get my list I want to
shout out
Simone Jones for from Birmingham England
thank you very much we have a new
executive producer on board son Rui or
Rui son I don't quite know how that
works especially from somebody in China
and they're from Shanghai China so thank
you son or Thank You Rui whichever one
it is that is your first name Jay Lee
from Putnam Valley New York thank you
buddy for coming on board and John
Matney from Clayton California and
finally let me say this right Jarek
tariffs from Bristol also from England
or Great Britain Thank You Jarek and of
course to the aforementioned executive
producers guarantee Amy Jones Michael
Langley Marc hrabowski again crusher
buddy Mark Griffith my buddy from
Washington
Wayne Chan Andrew Pollard who's again
running Leadville himself Bryan sands
Liz McCutcheon who was who's question
was asked and answered on the show and
brand new sun rui thank you for coming
on board really appreciated you guys and
to all my patreon supporters and
everybody who takes the time to download
and rate and review this show share on
your social media channels it means a
lot and I am humbled by just your
attention and your willingness to even
engage and download my content means a
lot considering the wealth of choices
out there as rich and I talked about
earlier and there is quite a lot so
thank you guys and my address here we
work here at billion films 1240
Rosecrans Avenue Suite 120 in Manhattan
Beach California nine oh two six six
nine oh two six six in USA of course
otherwise you can reach me at Billy and
pod on Instagram or at Billy yang Billy
at bill yang on Twitter
Billy Hank films and Billy yang podcasts
on Facebook and Pete please feel free to
write me at Billy and podcast at
gmail.com I think that is it did I cover
everything that is it thank you guys for
joining me for another episode of the
billion podcast my thanks once again to
mr. rich roll and to all of you guys and
please consider showing up help us sell
this thing out at the Wilshire Ebell
theatre rich Volcom slash appearances -
get your tickets this has been another
episode thank you guys and we will see
you guys on the next one
[Music]